tequila may look like many other sleepy
little towns as locals passed the time
in this quiet central Mexico city of
35,000 but not far from the town square
is one of the most recognizable company
names in business the headquarters of
Jose Cuervo tequila
we began producing tequila in 1758 even
though it wasn't until 1795 when the
king of Spain cattle the fourth gave us
the permit to produce and sell tequila
and that's when we considered the birth
of Jose Cuervo in 1795 unlike the slow
pace of this little colonial city the
pace inside one of Mexico's largest
companies is anything but slow producing
a whopping 230,000 liters of tequila
each and every day the tequila industry
is so strong around here an estimated 80
percent of the entire town's population
lives off the income generated from
tequila production tequila was first
distilled as a drink called hulk' by
Spanish conquistadors in the year since
the tequila has become a symbol of
Mexican pride and culture process
includes stripping the agave plant then
exposing the heart the pineapples as
they refer to them are then steamed
inside giant ovens for as long as three
days the next step is extracting the
juice from the cooked agave plant the
extraction is then brewed in giant
copper kettles as tequila doctors
measure temperature levels and monitor
the alcohol balance after the brewing
process the tequila cools off as workers
constantly monitor contents the liqueur
is eventually stored in barrels anywhere
from a few weeks to several years today
just about all of the world's tequila
from the state of Jalisco and especially
the city of tequila some tequila lovers
say the good tequila's ranked up there
with the best liquors it represents
tradition it represents culture it
represents Mexico